праця європейської солідарності
підтримує цей законопроект але насправді
колеги тут справа не лише у реєстрі
спрощеній чи не спрощені реєстрації у
цьому реєстрі волонтерів справа набагато
глибше тому що на жаль Ми зараз живемо в
реальністю Коли у нас масово
переслідують волонтерів і волонтерські
спільноти І якщо наприкінці вересня було
46 проваджень щодо якогось нібито не
такого ввезення гуманітарної допомоги
автомобілів для фронту то уже за різними
даними є понад 53 І хоча справа публічно
дещо притихла насправді Вона рухається і
переслідування відбувається у нас живемо
в реальності коли ми маємо правильних і
неправильних волонтерів тобто своїх при
офісних чи не своїх волонтерів і в
результаті ті хто свої вони є в
марафонах вони усюди висвітлюються а не
своїм будь ласка кримінальні справи
перевірки і багато різних Проблем у нас
відбувається також дивні сепаратні
наради на яких напрацьовуються різні
Можливо проєкти але депутатів від
опозиції і не своїх волонтерів туди не
запрошують у нас є багато зараз моментів
таких як наприклад коли військові
адміністрації мстяться за розголос про
кримінальні справи проти волонтерів і
блокують можливості включення реальних
волонтерів у системі шлях тому в даному
випадку ми маємо допомогти волонтерам бо
без них зараз би ми не втримали армії і
Я закликаю правоохоронні органи
перестати переслідувати волонтерів Я
закликаю військові адміністрації зробити
режим максимального сприяння нам
розказують що зараз армія на 100% буде
забезпеченам формою а служба логістики
доповідає лишень про 40% спроможності і
на 60% розраховує саме на волонтерів і в
реальний час біди саме волонтери
тримають нашу державу сьогодні тому руки
геть від волонтерів і максимально працює
для України